Amanda the adventurer a game that is
near and dear to all of our hearts and a
game that has been updated four times in
between now and the last time that I
played it I don't know if that's true
I'm saying it's true which is just as
good as it actually being true oh my God
I can move that's different oh my God a
happy family
a happy soulless demon family why is my
arrow possessed oh God
okay
this might be a problem why is that whoa
who's there
why does why is the shadows in the
corner look like Amanda why does that
look like Amanda the adventurer okay
whatever
all right it's so good I just get to
watch the tapes now
which is totally fine and understandable
[Music]
hi I'm Amanda yay and I'm bullied I love
Apple do you like Apple
you know it
yup
that's okay you should never be afraid
to try something new but we don't even
know where the store is
do you know where the store is yes I do
but I'm probably sure that you don't
want me to be mad you do to be me you to
be mad at me it's right there yeah
that's right let's go we're at the store
it sure looks crowded back and look
there are apples can you see apple
ah
say apple uh
um Apple
horrible good job now we can make apple
pies
uh it's on the floor now there's nothing
there's nothing I could ever do about
that oh hey wait a minute
[Music]
how did I even get in this place is this
my house I don't know if this is my
house I'm gonna episode
is that all that were made I don't know
I don't know
oh you
hey everyone I'm Amanda I'm Willy
today we're going to get me for Grandma
what is a grandma a vegetarian can you
tell us
oh no
tell us where the butcher is
no
the butter
no
no there it is let's go okay I gotta
remember what was it that I said before
could you tell the meat man what we need
what do I what did I say what do we need
oh did you tell the big man what we need
um
[Music]
okay
tell them what we need I
I don't know what you need that's right
uh-huh
[Music]
okay so so far this is all the same
right it's not different
oh boy
okay
man I didn't even get to tell what type
of meat I wanted I didn't even get
meat Islam was that what I was supposed
to type in
is that what I was supposed to type
because I don't know if I typed that
I don't know if I did that
can I try that again or was that the
other tape back there let me try
something here lamb
[Music]
oh oh interesting so that still holds
true wait a minute
why do I have more than one episode blue
why do I have multiple episodes blue
episode three wait a minute why do I
have multiple episode blue is zero
zero
zero
interesting I have two you're right the
treasure map said the woods let's go
I think we're close to the treasure now
aren't you excited bully
I said aren't you excited huh oh yeah
right
um yeah but we still don't know where
the treasure is uh buried
our friend the GPS said that x marks the
spot can you see where the x is no
actually I cannot marks the spot uh-huh
goes in the round hole
for the X
on the right right well that's left
Amanda you don't know your directions
looks like the spot
how are we supposed to get at it under
all the dirt
luckily I brought some tools to help us
with our adventure I brought a crowbar a
rope and a shovel we already used the
crowbar for the door we used the Rope
and now we only have the shovel man what
tool should we use to dig up the
treasure what do I keep seeing
disappearing in the center of it uh
Woolly I didn't bring that what can we
use to dig up the treasure
oh brains the only tool we have in youth
yet is the shovel with that said the
only tool we would need is
a backhoe ah damn it a shovel you're
right now we can dig this up before
someone okay that's enough no I I can't
let you do this anymore I don't care
what you do to me
you take the tape out now and Destroy
them burn them whatever just get rid of
these other tables do you hear me
you can't let anyone else watch this
I'm thinking you may start to care about
what a man is gonna do to you oh
ah
tape
man I don't know if anyone's ever told
you how to start a fire
that ain't it chief
excuse me uh
uh start over uh uh burnt
uh interesting
uh Amanda okay all right
uh uh you need
kindling
go left
[Music]
uh go my favorites
Ford's team I know how to spell it
huh yeah hey
um yeah no I found it yeah I found the
place it was just uh
you're just off the highway
yeah not too far right
um
yeah I know they're all hold on what
I was like was I followed
no I
no I don't think so who'd who'd be
following me
no nobody nobody was there it was just
me
um
yeah no the tapes are all just right
there they're gone every single one
yeah no no problem
um
listen it's getting late I uh
I really need to get home I got work
tomorrow so I'll
uh I'll call you when I get back home
okay
cool okay have a good night I'll uh talk
to you soon
bye
well if I froze the frames there I
probably would have seen something that
would have been useful for me but I
didn't so I don't know what it was
but also there
hey three okay I don't know three two oh
oh why why can I crouch oh to pick up
things off the ground okay so is this
different than that one is it the same
one always different
oh it's different
is this the one where I need to type
woolly
[Music]
spot was that beneficial in any way did
I was that
no Markiplier
where am I
am I uh who please
um
826 I see 826 that's not probably not
important eight two six eight two six ah
I see
so you would have showed it to me anyway
even if I typed it sooner
I see
I'll leave that on the ground there well
three two oh
two three two oh two I don't know if
that's good
I mean if it's just highlighting numbers
here then there's got to be
that'll be another number somewhere I'm
not sure if I should watch episode three
is the thing I'm thinking that episode 3
might close this out and then I might
not have all the things that I need
to leave
all right episode three it is
probably gonna be the end oh boy it's
dark out let's go home
but what about woolly
oh
I don't want to go home
to the house
I don't know if I want to
knock on the door
to go inside
that's not good
uh it's probably not good hmm
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well I knew that was gonna do that but I
didn't do it right oh God not episode
one I'm
fricked oh I gotta go through all that
again okay it wasn't that much let me
speed through it Speed Run maybe I saw
that Amanda I saw that with your face I
saw what happened there I saw hmm the
weird thing is episode one disappears
this is episode three this is the secret
episode with woolley's burial location
or something like that I'm woolly
ah man Amanda would also fit that one
wait a minute hold on a second
oh man
Amanda
okay so I don't know what's going on
with this map but it kind of coincides
with what's going on in the walls if you
take a look over here there's something
with an X up there and what I believe is
either a car or an Among Us character I
currently have three numbers that are
highlighted and there's got to be a
place where those are supposed to be
input
bye luckily I brought them what's going
on with that tree in the back there the
trees back there the trees are doing
something funny but I don't think it's
important uh Amanda I didn't bring that
you didn't bring Amanda okay what about
woolly only told we haven't used yet is
the shovel
Adventure all right I'm guessing that
here is where I need the code I need the
code here and I don't need it anywhere
else if I can get the code and I can put
it in here in this particular one then I
can figure this out and I'm gonna figure
it out with my big big brain and my big
big brawn
but mostly my brain this really reminds
me of the Unison this episode where
riddle Mark appeared and I was guiding
Ethan through my outdoor escape room or
whatever it was God I don't know why
very fun and as soon as honest
okay so the numbers were like oh three
two
something like that zero three two three
oh
uh
three two zero two three the thing is I
don't know which one comes first
[Music]
we can watch over here I know that
there's gotta be some other thing that
I'm missing here I don't think I have
enough information for this yet this
feels final because the answer would
obviously be to burn the tape so if you
can burn the tape then everything is
over so long as you don't watch episode
three then everything should be fine I
just wish this wasn't so long I need to
get to it but I'm in a brainstorm so
Amanda lives inside these tapes just
like the girl from The Ring and if you
watch it you die no matter what if you
keep watching you die but it seems like
if you keep watching and you don't
answer the riddle you don't get to leave
either you're trapped in this house who
knows if this is even your house it
doesn't have a bed it doesn't have a
kitchen it doesn't have a bathroom that
should be the most concerning part of it
with all that being said you're trapped
I'm trapped until we can get to the
bottom of this but episode one is gone
there might have been an answer in
episode one which would necessitate me
going back to the beginning because
that's the only time where episode one
is still in existence but until that
time comes it is gone but I don't know
if I need to restart this so there are
numbers on the wall that clearly
correspond to some kind of a code
there's got to be an order in which you
can watch them there's got to be an
order in which you can use them and
there's got to be one more there was
something in there I'm sure I would hate
that I would have to freeze frame to
come back to that but I can't do that
right now because I don't have the
technology for it what is she how long
has she been doing this don't watch it's
too late for me I'm sorry for what I've
done look at the bicep on Amanda there
don't do anything she says
don't let her take you shut up shut up
do not watch what was this doing in my
attic I see these everywhere what does
this mean what does this mean the first
one to appear was two then zero then
three then two there is only one place
in this that allows you to put in four
digits in this whole thing and that's in
episode two at the meat store if that's
all the numbers it is it must be some
combination of those numbers I think it
was two zero three two
what we need
it was two then zero
I was like you were you oh
is it
I've been trying to listen okay
uh-huh you know you will not be ready
what
what do you mean do I gotta board up my
door
what do I do
hello
hello
2023
like the year
[Applause]
man
ah
[Music]
I see I get it ah yeah I see okay but
anyway so apparently that's um that's
the new Amanda the adventure and the
code is literally to tell you when the
game is coming out but anyway that is
the update to Amanda the adventurer I
don't know if this is supposed to be an
indication of what will come in the game
later which it may with the 3D
exploration which I do like I wish it
was a bit more in this one but still
it's good to get an update on this game
because it does have a little creep
Factor uh there's something about that
like analog horror aesthetic retro CRTs
VHS all that crap the mythical ancient
equipment of the past so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and I look forward to an
update to this game and everything that
it will uh have for us in store if you
want more scary games I have so many on
my channel find your favorite comment
your favorite down below so other people
can know what your favorite is and as
always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]